Cambodian voters arrive early on Sunday
morning at this polling station in Phnom
Penh to cast their ballots for 125
members of parliament
prime minister Hansen's Cambodian
People's Party took all seats in the
last general election in 2018 and says
it's won overwhelmingly again
for me everything seems normal we
haven't been forced to do anything
everything's the same as before
as a Cambodian citizen my role is to
cast a ballot so I have to come to the
polling station to elect my leaders but
the United Nations has criticized the
polls for failing to be inclusive with
some critics going as far as calling it
a sham with voters turning up at this
polling station hour after hour there is
a semblance of an election but Alice say
none of the other parties participating
present a credible challenge to
consent's party after the main
opposition party the candlelight party
was disqualified in May
ahead of the election on Zen the world's
longest serving prime minister said his
son
could take his place within weeks
has kept his silence
just come to work today
human rights activists believe humanet
is likely to continue down the path his
father has
paved's entire training is in the
military so he sees things from a
military perspective first and foremost
and the second thing is that whom said
is not going anywhere he's going to
still be around he's going to be head of
the Cambodian people's party and he's
going to be looking over his shoulder
the country's Election Commission says
voter turnout was at more than 80
percent poll workers are telling the
votes but there's near consensus among
political observers the election was
over before it began